if there's one movie we never get tired
of watching its Mean Girls it's hard to
believe that 15 years have passed since
this hilarious movie first hit the big
screen we want to know what our favorite
characters are up to are any of them
still friends ended Cadi sorry we mean
Katie and Aaron make it to the finish
line watch until the end to find out
Karen Smith Karen Smith is the kind of
girl that everyone wants to be friends
with she's funny peppy and fun to be
around despite being considered as
ignorant and dumb karen is a lot smarter
than we were led to believe in fact some
people believe that she purposely comes
off as dense because she thinks being
smart is lame according to Janis Ian she
was one of the dumbest girls you will
ever meet
but thankfully her good looks and
charisma help her break the mold after
high school
since the plastics were roughly sixteen
years old and Mean Girls Karen should be
around 31 years old today and we'd like
to believe that she's highly successful
although this comes as a surprise to the
people who once knew her karen is at the
top of her game after making a name for
herself in the weather forecasts
business karen was given her own news
channel where she works as an anchor she
uses her fifth sense to foresee the
weather and is basically the celebrity
in her hometown despite being in a
strange on and off again relationship
with her first cousin set my Zukowski
karen is very much single she focused on
her career and lives a lavish life
filled with gorgeous outfits and
luxurious vacation destinations
Ms Norbury Ms Norbury is the type of
person who never gives up on the people
she loves despite being a highly
intelligent and kind woman
Ms Norbury often finds herself working
odd jobs to make ends meet when we first
met her in Mean Girls Sharron makes it
clear that she's going through a divorce
so we can only suspect that she's
working numerous jobs to pay for lawyer
fees among other things but now that
fifteen years have gone by we can only
hope that Miss Norbury is solely focused
on teaching 12th grade calculus although
her age was never displayed we think
that Miss nor Barry and Tina Fey the
actress who portrays her are of age so
this would make Sharon 48 years old
today
Ms Norbury is still coaching the North
Shore and mathletes
and helping students have positive high
school experiences principal Don Duval
still has minor feelings for Shane
but she's simply not interested in him
like that although some fans are
convinced that these two get married
after the plastics graduate from high
school we're not buying it sure they
might have danced together at the Spring
Fling but we think the sparks were
one-sided luckily mr. Duvall eventually
meets the woman of his dreams and gets
married but Miss Nora Berry isn't
interested in getting married again and
is now dating and living with a new
boyfriend Damien Lee Damion Lee is one
of the best characters in Mean Girls
he's hilarious witty and a fantastic
friend he's also known for having some
of the most memorable quotes ever
all in all Damien is a hoot and we
aren't the only ones who think so after
high school Damien struggles to find a
vocation that challenges and excites him
so he takes some time off and travels
around Europe it's here that he meets
his long-term Italian boyfriend who
eventually moves to America to be with
him his boyfriend loves how funny and
opinionated he is so he suggests that
Damien starts his own YouTube channel so
Damien does just that and quickly
becomes one of the highest-paid
youtubers of all time he does commentary
videos fashion hauls and makeup
tutorials
he also tends to do collaborations with
other YouTube stars all-in-all Damien is
living his dream and being himself he's
loved and supported and absolutely
entertaining but weights are gaming and
Janice still friends or do they go their
separate ways after high school keep
watching to find out Gretchen weiners
crutch and weiners family is so rich
that she doesn't have to work a day in
her life still Gretchen likes to get out
of the house and have fun so after high
school she gets a degree in business and
becomes the vp of her father's toaster
strudel Empire despite being an
independent and successful woman
Gretchen is the kind of person who needs
to feel like she belongs this was made
obvious when she ditched the plastics
only to join the cool Asians clique
after high school many of Gretchen's
Asian friends went on to attend far away
schools and left her behind so Gretchen
was in dire need of a new clique this is
when she stumbled upon a yoga studio and
got a membership after bonding with the
workers after Gretchen's father passes
away she sells his company and moves to
California to open up her own yoga
studio which she names such yoga believe
it or not but
got married to Jason after high school
fortunately for her they got divorced
after six months today Gretchen is a
vegan he was married to a yoga teacher
they have two kids and own a beautiful
California home although she and Karen
aren't as close as they used to be they
make it a point to go on prestigious
vacations together once a year but wait
what about Regina George
she's the queen bee a star those are the
two richest her little workers we'll
give you the inside scoop in a few
moments so don't go anywhere
Aaron Samuels Aaron Samuels is a super
sweet guy who's tired of being bossed
around by sneaky girls he dated Regina
George before dating Cady heron and
quickly learns that he likes people who
have authentic personalities after high
school Aaron goes on to attend
Northwestern University which is very
close to where katie lives
Katie and Aaron dates for a total of six
years before calling it quits however
they do so on amicable terms and two
years later Aaron gets married to his
dream girl and has a baby 32 year old
Aaron is now the father of a
seven-year-old girl and he's loving the
family life
although Katie and Aaron seemed to be
the real deal they spent too much time
apart which caused the relationship to
falter and since they had very different
plans for the future they agreed that it
would be best to split up and remain
friends
luckily Aaron got to cash in on Katie's
excellent math skills throughout his
entire educational journey she tutored
him for free and he passed his math
exams with flying colors okay no we're
joking he's so bad at math but she did
manage to get him a passing grade today
Aaron's a lawyer who fights for the
underdog which is super cruel mrs.
George mrs. George isn't a regular mom
she's a cool mom and she's an even
cooler grandma although it's been 14
years since her daughter Regina
graduated from high school mrs. George
is still acting like a teenager this is
because her youngest daughter Kylie has
kept her young at heart mrs. George is
now 47 years old but she doesn't look a
day over 35
thanks to her affinity for plastic
surgery since we last saw her she's had
her lips nose and eyelids enhanced among
many other things
since velvet pink track suits are no
longer in style mrs. George is often
seen wearing stilettos high-waisted
jeans and crop tops she's seriously
committed to having a youthful
and doesn't like it when her
granddaughter calls her grandma she much
prefers it when she calls her big sis or
mom in case you're wondering Regina
George doesn't have any daughters nope
it's her younger sister Kylie who had an
unplanned pregnancy during her senior
year in high school but we're not too
surprised about that considering how
cool of a mom mrs. Jia's it's not like a
regular mom I'm a cool mom
alone ah mrs. George is living her best
life and loves spending time with her
family she's still happily married to
mr. George who still has a hard time
accepting her extravagant ways Regina
George
the queen bee never sleeps and always
comes out on top although she may have
been outsmarted by Katy Janice and
Damien in high school she's never
allowed this to happen twice after
getting hit by a bus Regina pulled her
rage into sports and became a very
passionate lacrosse player unfortunately
for her her spine injury was deemed too
severe and she was forced to retire from
contact sports
after University Regina marries the son
of a real estate mogul she moves into a
mansion and lives a very lavish life
although she follows Gretchen and Karen
on Instagram they aren't really friends
anymore
however Regina makes sure to send them a
Christmas card every year to remind them
how good she's doing
Regina is still really good friends with
Kristen Hadley though so at least she
has someone Regina and her husband had 8
year old twin boys
Regina is their soccer and football
coach and she's absolutely terrifying in
fact she's the first woman to coach an
all-boys sports team in her hometown
parents are scared of her and treat her
with respect to ensure that their kids
get accepted into the local leagues in a
way Regina is still a plastic who loves
power and appearances however she's put
the burn book in the past and now trolls
people on social media instead Janis Ian
so you want to know if the trio is still
going strong and the answer is sort of
although Janis and Damian still see each
other on a daily basis they haven't seen
Katie in a couple of years however they
do make it a point to FaceTime whenever
the opportunity arises
Janis manages Damian's YouTube channel
and helps him come up with new topics
she's also his agent and since Damien's
becoming super popular she's managed to
land him some minor roles in upcoming
movies although we're used to seeing
Janis with black hair dark makeup and
gothic
Dean a lot has changed in the last 15
years in fact Damien gave Janice a
makeover on his channel and she looks
divine she now has a brown hair light
makeup and a classic style Janice and
Kevin the poor are married and have
three children they're very happy
together and live in a big house in the
suburbs
Janice Kevin and the kids are planning a
family vacation to Africa which will
take place in the summer of 2020 on top
of being Damien's manager and agent
Janice also teaches our classes at the
local library
Janice loves being a mom and enjoys
working with Damien these two BFFs are
never splitting up Betsy and chip Haran
before we can tell you what Katie's been
up to we figured we fill you in on how
her parents are doing both chip and
Betsy our research zoologist who loved
adventure and prefer the jungle life
over the city life after Betsy's tenure
with Northwestern University ran out
Katie's parents moved back to Africa
where they plan on retiring however they
waited until Katie was finished studying
before putting their house for self and
in barking on a brand new adventure
they're currently studying the Burmese
pythons behavioral patterns while
helping their villages local children
learn English
Betsy is still a huge fan of Ladysmith
Black Mambazo and chip has taken up wood
carving all in all the herons are loving
life and currently semi-retired but what
on earth has their daughter Katie been
up to let's go and find out Cady heron
after breaking up with Aaron and getting
her university degree and Katie chose to
move back to Africa with her parents
she's currently a zoologist and a famous
writer so simply put Katie studies and
documents African wildlife and makes
documentaries she's happily married to a
writer / director who she met while
filming her first documentary Katie
always planned to move back to Africa
which is one of the reasons why she and
Aaron didn't work out he just couldn't
pack up and leave the world as he knew
it fortunately her husband is used to
traveling around the world and more than
happy to settle down in Africa's rich
terrain while they don't have any
children yet katie is planning to have
her first and only child in about a year
it's been two years since Katie
officially moved back to Africa with her
parents and she misses her friends the
greatest people
ever meet Katy Janice and Damien
remained friends after high school and
she misses them terribly
luckily Janice and her family will soon
be visiting Katy in Africa so that's
something to look forward to in her
spare time Katy and her husband also
help build orphanages and Katy teaches
maths to the locals all in all life is a
lot simpler than it was in high school
but Katy has no regrets
so what do you think of our Katy's new
life are you surprised she moved back to
Africa let us know what you think about
these happily ever afters in the
comments below and that's a wrap
give this video a big thumbs up if you
wish Damien had a real youtube channel
and don't forget to hit that subscribe
button for more videos like this one
thanks for watching the things see you
next time
[Music]